all right thank you everyone for coming
it's introduced sorry introducing Emily
to talk about rust thank you for having
me so I hope that you're here today to
talk about rust and IOT with me if not
there are several other parallel talks
that I would absolutely be in if I
weren't speaking in this particular slot
so I've personally contributed to the
rest project in various ways for several
years now and in past lives I've built
all kinds of robotics and embedded
projects now you won't have heard of me
from the prominent embedded rust project
or the fantastic embedded rust book
because the experts who work on those
things know better than to try to fit a
summary into a 45-minute slot but that's
what I'm going to try to do for you when
I first proposed this talk to LCA there
wasn't a central repository of all the
scattered knowledge about doing rests on
embedded systems and between that time
and right now some amazing resources
have been produced that I will refer to
and refer to you to throughout the talk
so that frees up a bit of time that
might otherwise have been spent on facts
and details for a bit of an impromptu
birds of a feather session at the end so
that you can take advantage of what
really makes a conference like this
special which is the other humans and
experts in the room so what I'm going to
do at the end I'll ask everyone who
wants to connect with others about rest
whether that's recruiting for a project
of your own sharing a project that you
think is cool or asking for a project to
contribute to to give me a quick rundown
on what that is and I will thank you
with a little plush rust mascot for
doing so
you can then display that through the
rest of the conference and people that
will know to talk to you about rest so
first things first most of you probably
know a bit about the rest language it
attacks the apparent dichotomies between
human readable code versus fast
performing code ergonomic to develop
code versus verifiable
certified bug-free code by sweeping a
lot of problems under the rug of the
compiler they then build a compiler and
associated tool chain that's capable of
solving all of those problems to write
code free of certain classes of bug in
any language you need to follow a bunch
of rules and what sets rest apart is
that these rules live explicitly in the
language spec and in the compiler and
they're enforced at compile time rather
than at the time when you're thinking
and reasoning and designing the code or
at runtime like interpreted languages
often are so what we call safe rust is
the set of all programs that you know
are within this weird fractal barely
defined space of correct programs and
that means that there's going to be some
correct programs that you can't
necessarily prove are free from bugs
especially when it comes to Io any
interaction with the outside world and
so for those cases when you need to
write programs that are outside of what
you know it's safe but you as a
programmer think they're inside of
what's correct you use what's called
unsafe rest which does permit you to
write some programs outside of that
space of correct things also and the
language is under rapid and active
development to expand what's safe to
push the boundaries of safe so they get
as close as possible to the boundaries
of what the correct programs free of
memory misuse are and so if you've come
to my LCA talks in the past I've talked
about how the new bleeding edge features
that we're not sure whether they're
really going to land come out daily in
what's called the nightly rest Channel
some of them graduate to a beta Channel
and then a stable channel with the
tested features is released every six
weeks that's always backwards compatible
one thing that's new since last year and
since last we talked here about rest is
that they've also added the concept of
additions and additions are an opt-in
feature basically that allows wonderful
new syntax
wonderful ergonomics increased safety
that might not be backwards compatible
to the beginning of time so if you want
some backwards compatible feature you
don't have to opt into the addition but
if you want the newer cooler syntax like
saying use the crate instead of external
crates whatever then you can opt into an
addition with those features so to talk
about rust on IOT we need to pick a
definition for what this buzzword even
means
so IOT is a bunch of physical devices
with some kind of computer in them and
those devices interface with the
physical world through their inputs and
outputs and they interface with each
other and often a server over the
network often a public network what
could go wrong in practice this often
means a design pattern where you have a
bunch of individual little pieces of low
power low capability Hardware heavy on
the i/o that talk back to some
centralized server or database which
then does some heavier computation on
what has learned from them and possibly
sends obstructions back out to them as
to what outputs they should give into
the world so we need software on both
sides for a real IOT system both that
server side and the embedded devices
side of course is also the case of just
a mesh of little devices talking to each
other over a network and never actually
talking back to a server but that's less
common than the server case when you
need to interact with humans or interact
with an app that human is going to be
working with so both sides of this
equation the embedded low-level stuff
and the high-level server stuff can be
written in rust so most programmers find
working directly on the hardware to be
much less familiar and more challenging
than writing code that runs basically as
a server that central server or database
in most IOT design patterns is actually
super familiar if you've done web
development application development atop
an operating system
and that makes them a great place to
start if you're learning a new
programming language for the first time
there's often more mentors and resources
for running a program atop an operating
system then and it's easier to reproduce
for someone else to reproduce the error
you're getting then if you're going
directly on hardware plus writing atop
the operating system lets you avoid
thinking about a lot of hardware
problems that the operating system just
solves for you before you even notice
them so if you choose to start an IOT
project where you have a bunch of little
devices talking back to some server that
does something clever over the internet
you can choose to use a specification
such as the web thing standard which you
can learn about at the IOT mozilla.org
link and you can build on the work that
others have done to get the physical
hardware talking speaking that standard
and talking to that API that you expose
so you can get a working IOT project
doing minimal if any development on the
hardware to start with so the Mozilla
things project has a rest example where
you can write the server in rust their
example shows how to use the web think
rate to talk to a dimmable light bulb
and a humidity sensor that expose the
web thing API and you can talk to
anything that talks that API which you
can find in the wiki list of supported
hardware there so if you're interested
in learning more about building IOT
through this Web thing spec I'd
recommend Kathy Jory's talk tomorrow in
room a3 from 350 to 530 it's a workshop
on starting out with it she won't be
using rust but she will be using the
framework so I point this out because
when you run a program within an
operating system the standard library
makes all of these useful guesses about
what you want for topics like
multi-threading and i/o and various
primitives so it's better to avoid
reimplemented these features if you can
get away with it because that standard
library has been well tested for years
and years on a variety of platforms as a
rule of thumb
if a piece of hardware that you're
considering is used to run a Linux
derivative you can probably write rest
with the standard library for targeted a
great example of this and probably in
the room here right now is Wesley
Moore's ePaper badge for this conference
whose code is written in rust with the
source at that github link right there
so he runs a Linux derivative on a
Raspberry Pi which means a regular old
rust program can interface with the
peripherals like the ePaper screen
through that operating system Leslie
could I ask you to raise your hand if
you're here so there he is if you want
to talk to him later on so what about
the embedded case what about the tiny
little chips the ones with the power
size or price constraints that rule out
the possibility of running an operating
system to run your program on writing
software for these like writing the
operating systems themselves is called
embedded programming when you don't have
an operating system exposing those
multi-threading those i/o primitives to
your standard library you obviously
can't use a standard library and instead
you have to be much more explicit about
how you want your program to perform
those tasks so micromanaging how the
hardware is used means that the output
code is less portable across different
platforms and more difficult to compile
across platforms
fortunately rust provides support out of
the box for quite a few different
architectures so rust categorizes its
support for different families of chips
in what it calls tears so the tier one
is guaranteed to work so every change to
rust runs tests they build the code they
test the code on that architecture and
if it fails then they go back and fix it
before pushing that change tier to is
guaranteed the build
they'll build the code for that
architecture and if it builds good
enough they don't necessarily have the
hardware available to test the code on
that architecture and tier 3 is
basically this might work but we don't
really make any promises because there's
not the resources available to
do that continuous building for it and
continuous testing on it that tears one
and two may have so those different
levels of testing basically correlate to
whether you're likely to be the first
one to find some bug that a test might
have caught if you want a full list of
all of the supported architectures and
platforms you can check out the rest
Forge they have a wonderful list with
the cargo support and all of the details
on there so what happens if you want the
target a platform that isn't supported
yet you can add support but the
difficulty of doing that will vary based
on whether the tools that rust uses are
already ported to that platform or not
so to understand the different processes
you can use to address support to some
other architecture that doesn't have it
yet
let's quickly recap what a rust program
goes through as it's being compiled so
when you compile rest code it goes
through a series of steps first the
compiler makes what's called Mir which
is an intermediate representation of
that code within rust that mirror is
what your IDE can use to expose any
errors in your code as you're writing it
and relatedly if you're not using it
rust integration with our IDE yet I
would strongly recommend checking out
our we IDE yet comm which will tell you
exactly what the status is and where to
get that integration so after Mir they
make LLVM which is the low-level virtual
machines intermediate representation so
the LLVM IR and that goes to a big old
utility the LLVM that does optimization
on it to optimize away any code that's
irrelevant to the final outcome of your
programs behavior and the LLVM converts
the IR into a runnable program so if you
want to see what your code looks like at
each of these steps which is really
interesting to see where did those
abstractions go away
when did they go away you can either use
the emit flag to rest see to tell it
emit azzam emit LLVM IR emit near a
limit LLVM byte code whatever it is that
you want to see or if you're not
depending on a lot of other crates and
you're just curious you can hop into the
rest play pin at play trust Lang org and
under the little Run button up in the
corner you can ask it to show assembly
or show IR for that particular program
that you've pasted it in so to figure
out whether you're embedded device is
supported or can be supported by rest
you first check whether its architecture
appears as a target in that platform
support list that I linked earlier if
it's not there have a search around the
web to see whether LLVM can target it
yet if you find that you're working on a
platform that has LLVM support but
doesn't have rest support yet contact
the rest embedded working group for
guidance on how to add it to rest if you
don't want to use LLVM let's say you're
not on architecture that it does support
but you want to omit rust code for it
you can also try a project called crane
lift cream lift used to be known as
Croton so you've probably heard of it
even if it sounds a bit new right now so
it's an alternative code generator and
it takes in a slightly lower level
intermediate representation than LLVM
uses and you can use it from rust see
just the way you'd use LLVM and it's
primarily targeting larger regular like
x86 kind of things but it's written in
rust so if you want to write rust to add
support it's a good place to look and
regardless of which code generator you
prefer if you want to add a new target
to rest you do have to add it to some
code generator and that's a bunch of
work there's one other workaround that
you can consider so if you don't have if
you do have a platform that you can
write C for but you can't generate rest
code for that platform through either of
the code generators you can try turning
your rust into C and then compiling that
C through whatever methods you were
using anyways I tend Miss Anne kiss
this to get rest running on the esp8266
by compiling rust in to see with the in
rust c compiler and then putting that c
through the usual tool train to target
that board you can see his project and
scripts at that github link that I've
got on the screen the drawback of using
M rust see is that on its own it doesn't
do the same Baro checking and validation
that regular rust C does so it just
hopes that you passed it valid rust to
start with you can make sure that you've
got valid rest by running it through
rust C first but if you don't if you
skip that step you can introduce all
kinds of errors so finally you might
find yourself in a situation where you
want to use some C code alongside some
rust code or a little bit of rust code
alongside some C code in an embedded
context and if that's the case the
embedded rust book goes into great
detail on how to impure operate between
embedded rust and embedded C if you want
to take advantage of existing C code in
this kind of way
check out the embedded rest book at that
link additionally if you're integrating
between C and rust you'll probably find
yourself spending a lot of time writing
foreign function interface bindings
between the two some of that binding
writing challenge can be automated using
the crate called bind gen but you can
find on crates tayo
so if you're working without the
standard library where do the primitive
types and the methods come from so even
when you opt out of the standard library
most rust programs will have the cork
rake available it doesn't help you with
IO and multi-threading in the same way
that the standard library does but it
still exposes a bunch of the primitives
and the macros that you're used to
having you can find all of the core
crate docks and compare them to a
standard library docks there on the rest
side so if you're on a chip that's more
powerful and you think it could run
something kind of like the standard
library but that won't work for some
reason you may find yourself wanting to
make a custom standard library and this
is a workflow that's also supported
tool you want in that case is called
zargo it's like cargo but with an X
instead of a c4 cross-compiling if
you're watching this talk on the
recording after 2019 sagas sister root
building features may very well have
finished integrating into cargo so check
its wiki and if it says yay we'll ended
in cargo now just use the cargo features
instead so after all that let's hope
that you've found a device with a story
for targeting it with rust
maybe that story's LLVM maybe that story
has used crane lifts maybe that story is
work through with see tool chain so next
check out the awesome embedded rust repo
link there which is another new thing
since I initially proposed this talk to
find what support crates and example
code are available for your platform so
many popular embedded platforms have
several support crates that are already
written for them remember to check the
rest versions that they use and have a
look at the activity the recent activity
for the repository of the project when
evaluating whether it's still active or
whether this was someone's weekend
project several years ago and may
require a bit more effort than you
thought to get it up to date so if
you've only been doing regular rests
atop an operating system so far you'll
be almost overwhelmed by all of the new
words and concepts that pop up when you
jump into embedded development and many
of these concepts are just common to all
embedded development everywhere
but they kind of seem scary when they
all come at you at once
so I'd like to go through a few of the
first things that you'll need to be
acquainted with when writing rest target
an embedded system first you'll see a
bunch of references to hell the hardware
abstraction layer not the 2001 musical
machine so this expresses the way that
those standard functions that you'd
normally get through the operating
system should be performed on a
particular CPU family so how crates for
a given board that you're working on are
a great place to find example code as
well
since the person who wrote the hell
crate usually did it as a side effect of
trying to get some other more compelling
project working on that hardware for
instance the tomu that's Tom's open
micro USB device was developed by
members of our own LCA community and
it's helped create linked right there
includes some wonderful examples of how
to blink the LED and how to boot it up
just to get the user started with doing
anything with that crate so while an
embedded board is really good at
interfacing with the inputs and outputs
in the environment the sensors the
lights
the motors whatever that might be
they're generally really lacking in the
human readable output Department if your
program fails in some way while it's
running on the board maybe it can blink
an LED at you and that's generally about
it so in order to get actual useful
debug information off of a program while
it's running on an embedded system
you're going to probably want a
technique known as semi hosting so this
is where the code is connected to the
host machine probably your development
environment and it can put its errors
and panics back to your console and log
them out for you to analyze later on so
just basically look for a semi hosting
crate for your platform or family of
platforms and then you can log messages
from your chip as it has them back to
your host machine there's a fantastic
example of semi hosting in the embedded
rest book for the cortex-m that they're
using in their examples so definitely
look for that if you want I owe in a
useful feedback kind of sense
another challenge of designing embedded
rest programs is another site of the i/o
heavy nature of all of the IOT stuff
although the compiler can check the
logic in your program it doesn't know
enough about what the peripheral devices
attached to your board might do to make
any guarantees about them but the print
simples behind writing memory safe code
still apply to writing safe interfaces
to your peripherals for anything that we
can read or write even if it's a
peripheral device we want either one
mutable that is writable reference to it
at any give at any time or we can have
as many readable ones as we wanted the
way that you enforce this when it comes
to an external device is using the
singleton design pattern because when
you use Singleton's that helps the
compiler verify that there's only one
instance of this peripheral in the code
and once you know there's only one place
in the code that's going to be pointing
at let's say they are networking chip
the little cell phone that the cartoon
chips have then the borrow checker can
help your reason about whether it's
possible for the code to ever try to
read and write it simultaneously which
is the huge no-no the alternative to
using the singleton pattern would be to
use mutable global state to store that
code that represents the peripheral but
that's guaranteed to be unsafe because
you can't make any promises about
whether the other parts of your program
may try to write it while you're trying
to read it or vice versa at any point in
time so another way to improve the
compilers ability to reason about your
peripherals is to model them as state
machines a state machine is just a
representation of which of several valid
conditions the peripheral can transition
between from which other ones like if I
was in the state of waiting to give my
talk then I had to get on stage give the
intro give the talk and then take
questions it would be illegal to go
directly from waiting to speak to taking
questions it just wouldn't make sense so
by quantifying that common sense in your
code it helps the compiler check whether
any of your assumptions have been or
could be violated
so abstractions like oh yes express your
peripheral as a state machine are
written with a lot of lines of code and
this probably makes you worried that
they'll produce larger or slower
programs after compilation but then you
a bunch of struts that don't actually
hold any data to represent the states
which might seem kind of unnecessary
until you realize that as it compiles
down as long as they're empty they'll
just get compiled away because it's
smart enough to realize it's got nothing
in it can't have enough of it it'll
never be needed at runtime so you can
get the benefit of having the logic
expressed by these empty abstractions
without the cost of having them alter
the code that's produced at the end
that's the zero cost abstraction that
recitations go on about and it's when
you get basically the best of both
worlds
another challenge in writing embedded
software is concurrency if you take no
special precautions around concurrency
it's possible that you might be halfway
through doing something that you really
don't want to get interrupted with like
reading or writing something and then an
interrupt fires and changes the state of
that thing you were working with and
then who knows what's gonna happen
afterwards you get undefined behavior
and that's what we're trying to avoid
so instead there's three ways that you
can tackle concurrency in your code the
first way to handle concurrency is to
avoid it don't handle interrupts and if
you need to get the state of something
around you just pull it when you have
time to for some devices especially
those that upload data every so often or
toggle their output upon detecting some
condition that persists over time this
can actually be a perfectly viable
solution and avoiding concurrency all
together makes programs easier to write
and easier to reason about in debug but
it's often not possible so instead when
you need to handle concurrency on a
board that supports it you can use
atomic operations that are provided by
the instruction set of the device that
you're targeting for instance if you're
using a cortex m3 you'll have atomic
operations for reads and writes that
will just retry until they're successful
if something that can't be interrupted
was going on when they first tried to
happen for earlier Clarke acts as though
you won't have those so if you're bored
and you're he'll create support Atomics
they can let you do important operations
without the risk of them getting
interrupted or ever getting forgotten to
get done but what if you don't have them
the final
if you've got to have concurrency and
you can't do Atomics is you can just
temporarily disable interrupts while the
important pieces of code are executed
but leave them on the rest of the time
when the less critical code is going on
so those areas where there's no
interrupts allowed are called critical
sections and the syntax for them will
vary based on the crates that you're
using to target your particular
architecture so they do have the
drawback that if an interrupt just gets
ignored then you have to figure out
what's going to happen but that's less
problematic than getting the undefined
behavior of interrupting at the wrong
time so finally one of the parts of CPU
behavior that you're gonna have to
micromanage well you don't have an OS
helping you is telling it what all the
registers do the registers are just
little spaces in memory where the
processor stores little specific pieces
of information each one has an address
and some of them store special
information where the CPU will always
look to that place for that fact and
others can hold whatever you want them
to so using the right specialized
registers matters a lot because an
instruction might read from a particular
register and if you have the wrong thing
there nothing is going to work as
expected so one of your jobs as an
embedded programmer is to tell rust
about what register is that target
platform has available and what they do
rather than writing everything out by
hand you can define your registers using
a tool called SVD to rust that's based
on the system view description of format
files that are often provided by chip
manufacturers that are a standard way of
telling you what all the registers are
and it can convert these into support
crêpes if you search crates tocayo for
SVD to rest plus the name of the chip or
chip family that you're targeting
somebody might have already made this
support crate for you and provided it so
otherwise you can use the SVD to rest
tool itself to turn an SVG file into a
rust compatible expression of what those
registers are so if you're interested in
learning more about embedded or
low-level rest by reading it the
any operating systems that are written
in rust can be a great place to see it
really pushing the boundaries so a few
of those the red ox OS is probably the
most famous of those and it runs on the
nightly rust that has all of the cool
new features there are others though
Robo Galia is trying to improve the rest
ecosystem around the SEL for microkernel
so if that's something that interests
you check out their site and if you'd
really just like to be walked through a
teaching operating system that comes
with a book explaining systems concepts
as they apply to it check out Intermezzo
s-- which is exactly that teaching OS to
help programmers transition into systems
programming so another thing to call out
especially since we're talking about IOT
today is that there's the top operating
system and project they're at Taco S org
that offers a couple of open hardware
boards and is customized for them that's
focused on improving the IOT ecosystem
so if open hardware is a big deal to you
and you want to go buy a board or
produce a board that has a huge amount
of rust support seriously consider their
hail and I mix products so as I
mentioned at the start of this talk
rusts embedded resources have expanded
so much even just in the ten months
since I proposed this talk to fill what
felt at the time like a gap in their
documentation so there's now an embedded
working group with an IRC channel and
the handle rest embedded on Twitter so
you can absolutely join them ask them
questions they are the experts there's a
couple of books out the embedded nomicon
and the debugger nomicon this is a
common naming convention for how to
write unsafe rest is just always the
nomicon if you would like to go into
more detail and the working groups
repository has a bunch of things
including they're working at the moment
on a repository and a website of
showcasing a bunch of cool embedded
projects that's not ready yet but pretty
soon they'll be ready for poles
proposing your own rest in
that projects to be showcased there and
if you're just getting started in
embedded development I'd strongly
recommend the rest embedded discovery
book which is focused on teaching people
about how to use microcontrollers who
haven't used microcontrollers before and
just happening to use rest as the
language they do it in so with that I've
basically surveyed the core concepts of
embedded rest to hopefully launch you
out into doing or continuing your own
rest project and I would like to use the
rest of the time that's available to me
these last 15 minutes to have more or
less a mini buff the way that I would
like this to work is I'd like to hear
from those of you who have rust IOT
projects or distress projects or want to
start one so put up your hand we'll come
around with a mic and tell us basically
these questions what's your favorite
rest IOT project or the project you
contribute to or that you're looking for
what kind of help and feedback does it
need what should people search to find
it online and for everybody that shares
a project up until I run out I have a
little rest mascot for you and if we
give you one of these please display it
through the conference and if you want
to talk about rest to someone find
someone with the mascot on them and you
will know that they are a friendly rust
nerd so if you have questions we can
take questions in the end at the end
outside but I would recommend talking to
the experts who are using and doing
these projects because so many questions
our value judgments and matters of
experience and opinion that you will get
a better answer from polling several
people who've tried it at different
times than from asking any one speaker
so with that let's start going around to
for people to share their IOT rust stuff
mm-hmm
hi thanks Emily I'll stop I'm William
Brown or first year online my I have a
number of projects one of them is a lifx
based light bulb controller which is for
my home network it also does party hard
mode so you can turn your house into the
rave that you've always won
generally what I do is I actually
specialize in concurrency Pallo
algorithms and unsafe code I think the
life extractor and have unsafe so I'm
love to help you with your project so if
you want some mentoring please come and
talk to me about this stuff thank you
hi I'm Kate Stewart and I'm with the
Zephyr project and so one of the things
we're interested in obviously is running
on OS very lightweight OS and so I'm
sort of curious is there any work being
done on having a rust aport rust
standard library port into Zephyr to be
running with it do you know of I'm not
I'm not personally aware of is that
report off the top of my head but there
could very well be one quietly being
discussed or worked on online that I
just don't happen to have seen yet
because I haven't looked for it so I
would strongly recommend both searching
it and asking the embedded working group
in their Channel and asking around the
Zephyr community because things are
often just quietly not quite open yet
because people aren't quite happy with
them yet for quite some time before they
become really public and easy to find
cool thanks all right it's more of a
generic rust related question rather
than IT project I'm afraid so I work for
arm who create load of CPI P one of the
issues that we have is engaging with the
rust community to ensure the rust is
properly ported supported ensuring that
rust has support for all latest features
and whiz-bang blinky things that we
decide to throw in that our partners
want to create whatever else do you have
any recommendation suggestions pointers
as to how we can facilitate the wider
Ross community much better absolutely so
I would say that the
core team is your best point of contact
there and if you go to the core team and
ask for their feedback on your current
engagement with the community then they
can probably point you exactly where you
can help best there is a bit of a
concern in that rest is a fully
volunteer project some people are paid
to work on rust but that's generally
less for their particular company's
needs and so there's there's some
ambiguity in your comment about whether
or not you're expecting here's some
hardware please implement all of the
things for us if that's the case then
making sure that there is something in
it for the people doing the
implementation can help a lot if that's
if that's not the case just I think
working working directly with the core
team working with the infrastructure
team if you're concerned about the test
story for instance if you're like why
aren't you why isn't this tier 1
why aren't you testing building and
testing everything on it maybe it's we
don't have the hardware because no one
has provided us with hardware and/or no
one's running the hardware or whatever
that might be and whatever that answer
is so the question what can we do to get
this to a higher support tier and to
contribute better they will be able to
point to you in the best direction for
that engagement and we could brainstorm
later on about community involvement
strategies about basically marketing
your project maybe have a better about
better publicizing what can be done with
it but let's continue for now I would be
delighted to talk to you after about
just ideas for how to make it better
known hi great talk I just wanted to
mention a big part of IOT is obviously
the mobile applications to interact with
those we've recently started using rust
for iOS and Android in production and
we've found it to be brilliant like the
Android bindings and I at the iOS
bindings are just excellent so if you
are making an IIT device consider using
rust because then you
use rust for your device itself and also
for the core parts of iOS and Android
might save you some time fantastic
absolutely thank you for that feedback
we've got one night yeah got lots of
people good for it alright I I actually
come from the other way I'm an embedded
developer on microcontrollers dissing
say and I'm wondering so there's
obviously a way to foresee and Russell
talk to each other but whether there is
any plans or hopefully implementation to
be also able to reuse all the tooling
that's available for C because there's
some really really nice things such as
streaming trace to actually see all if
your executions in one place and things
like from if I'm not mistaken existing
artists integration where you can see
several threads and what are their call
stacks are and also things like having a
microcontroller that can support
external memory interface so you have an
internal SRAM and external DRAM which is
slower and bigger and being able to
access they say yeah personally familiar
with what the state of the art and that
is however I would strongly recommend
stopping by the rest embedded working
groups channel and asking them what
they're doing and what they want to do
with that and they'll likely point you
towards some people who are quietly
working on it or quietly thinking about
it thank you
maybe it's partially overlapping with
his question but what's the debug story
right now because I used rust about one
year ago for as Jas stuff and I got
stuck into debugging is really really
hard
awesome Jes is also kind of new platform
so it's not just rust being immature but
what about you know embedded programming
so yeah debugging is absolutely hard I
don't know of a language in which you've
been embedded debugging is necessarily
easy if there's a language in which it's
radically easier and they have a tooling
story that makes it radically easier I'm
pretty sure that the developers and
myself would love to hear about how we
could adopt that the
the deep backstory I mean you want.i is
that an answer up there ah yes what is
your possible answer mm-hmm I will sorry
I'm really giving my volunteers their
exercise so on embedded I've used a
product called black magic Pro before
which is basically it gives you a serial
port to a JTAG interface and I've
actually messed around a bit with using
rust on that and you do get coarse tax
and you can put breakpoints and stuff
like that on and you don't have to worry
too much about LOD be talking to your
device and stuff so I can recommend if
you're using your cortex and 0 or cortex
m3 check out a black magic probe it's
not amazing debugging but it will give
you 10 of the very basics of you know
cost accents oh thank you for the
suggestion and yeah the best tool is
very likely to vary per platform and
black magic is open source thank you for
that add-on hi I'm Wes I run a little
project called read rust which collects
blog posts from the Ross community and
it's a bit of a future call for the
participate participation but currently
working on a version 2 that would let me
recruit other people to help post the
the articles and approve them so if
anyone's keen to get involved I'm also
working on this new version being based
on it already uses a bunch of rust tools
but the new version is going to be built
there's a brass web server as well so
there'll be some coding involved as well
it's still early days so tell these
little couple of months off before I'd
need extra people but yeah if anyone's
interested come see me fantastic I guess
you
inspiration he was so I've been using
these Nordic based embedded chips which
is a Bluetooth low-energy chipset with
an arm in for embedded and I was
interested to look at the rust IOT so I
thought well maybe I can help wimp into
it but I looked and there's actually a
seemingly relatively mature project for
it already so I guess what I'm excited
to see is there's actually quite some
mature ecosystem around rust embedded so
yeah I'm gonna try it out and I guess
the expression to others is even if you
think it's more obscure maybe there's
already stuff going on the rough space
for it and you may not have to stuff
from scratch yes absolutely
thank you for that feedback because I've
been surprised as well I'm like I've
never even heard of this architecture
and yet it's got robust rust things
happening not particularly IOT related
but I'm in the middle of writing some
rust code for graph algorithms a port of
an earlier c module with a particular
emphasis on the fact that lots of
problems involve standard graph
algorithms but you don't usually want to
change all your data structures into the
form that most graph libraries want them
in order to do that so if anyone wants
to assist with that particularly if they
know the sort of rustic idiom ways of
doing things then that would be most
appreciated fantastic looks like we have
time for one or two more anyone else up
there all right not quite an IOT
projects but it is embedded if anyone
doesn't know these Sony cameras actually
can run Android so what started out as
an attempt at porting over the Google
HDR app to try and get amazing photos
out of it
and then installing Instagram on that
which I can post directly to anyone does
I've been looking at playing around with
computer vision with one of these and
yeah have it talk to me later if you
want to see where I'm at fantastic one
down here as well
No anais a project and something I
haven't really done that much in a while
is stuff to work try and make sort of a
screenshotting slash video recording
thing in rust that we'll be able to
catch frames to turn a presentation into
a bunch of slides because you have
transitions and more little things
having the points come up which is hard
to capture apart from screenshotting but
i wanted to capture basically everything
in the state to turn into a bunch of
images with timestamps and when optimize
it down and so it's in the state of it
was working on Windows and then I
realized but I'm actually not doing it
well when it didn't work where it was
that we wanting it to work yeah all
right well it looks like we're just
about at time thank you everybody for
your feedback and your publication of
your various rest and rest IRT project
so you can get these slides and notes at
that link you can find me on Twitter or
on IRC and I will be around we can do a
rest-pause later if anyone wants a rest
buff just postal a chat list and